[Musique]
bonsoir à tous mardi 8 janvier bienvenue
dans le 7-8 journal de tv 78 tout de
suite les titres
le grand débat national voulu par
emmanuel macron doit débuter le 15
janvier les maires yvelinois de
génération terrain eux ont déjà pris le
pas ils sont venus au président de la
république 2000 contributions collectées
auprès de leurs administrés les élus les
présenté ce matin lors d'une conférence
de presse c'est le grand rendez-vous du
numérique et de l'innovation le cs
computer electronics show a débuté
aujourd'hui à las vegas des yvelinois y
participent comme l'entreprise
saint-quentinoise sky one portal qui
présente au salon une solution immersive
dans le secteur de la santé enfin demain
top départ des soldes d'hiver pour un
mois elle se déroule jusqu'au 19 février
dans cette édition reportage au centre
commercial parly 2 au chesnay où les
enseignes se prépare pour la période et
trois invités viendront également sur ce
plateau bernard de bonneville et eric à
un nicolas pour le comité des yvelines
de l'association valentin haüy elle fête
cette année ses 130 ans est la
révélation rap du moment dans les
yvelines carta à une semaine de
l'ouverture du grand débat national les
maires de l'association génération
terrain ont remis hier au président de
la république un document intitulé nos
idées pour la france il regroupe 2000
contributions recueillies auprès de
leurs administrés ont fait le point avec
aurélien que ce soit dans les halls d
hôtel de ville sur internet ou les
réseaux sociaux durant trois semaines
les élus de génération terrain ont
recueilli les doléances de leurs
administrés une initiative qui fait
suite à leur rencontre le 7 décembre
dernier avec le président emmanuel
macron 2000 contributions ont ainsi été
récoltés dans quinze communes yvelinoise
saint germain en laye de sujets de
thématiques principales la fiscalité une
opposition on pouvait s'en douter au
rétablissement de dsf et puis une autre
thématique qui a été très très très
importante
la baisse du train de vie de l'état et
la baisse de la dépense publique
l'expression démocratique avec la prise
en compte du vote blanc ou encore les
retraites font également partie des
préoccupations exprimées par les
citoyens des thèmes quelque peu en
décalage avec les thématiques choisies
pour le grand débat national
il était important que les différents
interlocuteurs
nos gouvernants puissent s'imprégner
sans filtre sans ambages sans thématique
particulière de ce que ressentent les
administrés et quelles sont leurs idées
pour la france
intitulé nos idées pour la france le
document regroupant les 2000
contribution a été remis au président de
la république ainsi qu'au premier
ministre et au président du sénat une
semaine avant le coup d'envoi du grand
débat national en ce mois de janvier ses
traditionnels les mères présentent leurs
voeux à la population hier c'est
bertrand guillon qui a ouvert le cycle à
magny les hameaux une cérémonie à la
maison de l'environnement placée sous le
signe de l'écologie le maire manico a
souhaité que 2019 soit une année de
prise de conscience sur la transition
écologique
l'élu espère l'ouverture d'un débat
citoyen l'échelle européenne celui qui
est également vice président de saint
quentin en yvelines en charge du
développement durable et de la ruralité
a d'ailleurs critiqué l application du
plan climat air énergie territorial
texte adopté en septembre dernier au
conseil communautaire
écoutez bertrand ou lyon au micro de
mélanie poker
aujourd'hui il ya un plan climat énergie
qui a été voté qui a été voté à
l'unanimité
il ya eu aucun débat aucune discussion
là dessus tout le monde était pour tous
et puis après au final je m'aperçois que
c'est pas forcément le cas quand faut
mettre en place les actes
et bien derrière il ya des reculs il ya
des remises en question c'est dommage
parce que on a tellement aller gagner
ensemble dans une agglomération qui est
asphyxiée par l'automobile qui est
rempli de bâtiments passoires
énergétiques en fait qui est une
agglomération qui a été construite dans
les années 70-80 il faut totalement
changer le modèle d'homme si bertrand au
lion espère qu'il ya un grand projet
émerge également cette année pour la
firme de bulles loyer fermé à manille
depuis plusieurs années dans l'actualité
politique également deux députés et les
rues même des yvelines menacé de mort
aurore bergé et marie lebey qu'ont
révélé sur twitter et des courriers
qu'elle avait reçu les propos employés
dans une dans un orthographe
approximatif ils sont virulents et
intimidant toutes deux affirment ne pas
vouloir céder face aux menaces elles ont
reçu de nombreux soutiens celui du maire
de poissy karl olive ou encore de la
secrétaire d'état chargée de l'égalité
femmes/hommes marlène schiappa deux
invités m'ont rejoint en plateau eric à
nicolas et bernard de gonneville bonsoir
ça alors bernard de belleville vous êtes
le président du comité des yvelines de
l'association valentin haüy erika
nicolas vous êtes professeur de braille
pour cette association qui vient en aide
on le rappelle aux personnes déficientes
visuelles déjà bon anniversaire à bout
puisque l'association fête cette année
ses 130 ans on dira un mot sur sur cet
anniversaire dans cet entretien il ya
quelques jours c'était la 17e journée
mondiale du braille cet alphabet a été
développée au sein de l'institution
l'institut pardon royal des jeunes
aveugles fondée par valentin haüy louis
braille présente son alphabet dans cet
institut pour la première fois en 1827
et près de cent deux cents ans plus tard
le braille est ce que c'est encore
quelque chose de primordial pour les
personnes aveugles et malvoyantes
oui bonsoir je voudrais d'abord faire un
petit retour sous louis braille oui
parce que si cette journée du braille a
lieu le 4 janvier c'est que le 4 janvier
est la date anniversaire de louis
braille qui était née le 4 janvier 1889
qui elles n'ont que deux cent dix ans
près de meaux en seine-et-marne et
l'histoire de louis braille et bell
c'était un petit garçon de 4 ans
turbulent comme tous les petits garçons
de quatre ans son père était bourrelier
il travaillait le cuir et on l'avait dit
louis tir a pas joué que les instruments
pas pareil
bien sûr louis comme tous les petits
garçons il est allé jouer les
instruments de papa et avec par un geste
malheureux hills et crever un oeil avec
un des couteaux de son père et puis
cette époque-là l'hygiène était ce
qu'elle était l'infection s'est propagé
au deuxième oeil et le pauvre petit
louis braille s'y retrouvaient donc
aveugle à 4 ans et son père a remarqué à
ce moment là que malgré sa cécité
ils arrivèrent connaître les couleurs
des cuirs rien qu'avec le toucher donc
il a inscrit louis braille dans
l'institut royal des jeunes aveugles que
vous avez cités et la louis braille qui
était intelligent comme tout s'est rendu
compte que les systèmes de lecture qui
existaient à l'époque pour les aveugles
qui a été des lettres en relief par
exemple était vraiment insuffisant et il
a développé son alphabet braille à base
de 6 points et l' erika va pouvoir en
parler beaucoup mieux coin et d'ailleurs
professeur de braille erika nicolas
c'est aujourd'hui quelque chose de
primordial ce cet alphabet braille au
quotidien pour les personnes malvoyantes
et aveugles
ben disons que c'est très utile passera
par exemple sur les boîtes de
médicaments
on en lit fréquemment donc c'est très
utile mais malheureusement il n'y a que
10 % des aveugles qui lisent braille
donc c'est très difficile de de passer
aux voiliers de se dire qu'on a besoin
du braille pour lire psychologiquement
c'est une barrière à passer aussi
comment ça fonctionne le l'alphabet
braille
en fait ça fonctionne c'est six points
ces petits points à partir de là donc je
vous ai mis des exemples de lettres et
de chiffres
donc ils sont en noir par dessus et à
partir de ces six points ont fait 63
combinaisons et on peut faire toutes les
haines de l'alphabet les chiffres les
ponctuations les
le solfège enfants tous il ya vraiment
tout qui peut se faire à partir du
braille la promotion de ce cet alphabet
pour l'association valentin lui c'est un
enjeu primordial aussi c'est un enjeu
important
cette promotion du braille oui c'est un
enjeu important parce qu'il ya une
fausse idée qui circule et qui est que
les nouvelles techniques numériques vont
tuer le braille et que le braille n'est
plus nécessaire parce que l'informatique
adapté pour remplacer le braille c'est
parfaitement faux le le braille et
l'informatique ne sont pas concurrents
ils sont complémentaires et en
particulier je vais vous montrer les et
en particulier pour les jeunes qui
tombent aveugle très jeune et qui ont
besoin de faire des études
il est indispensable de passer au breil
si on ne connaît pas le braille et qu'on
est aveugle de naissance dont on est
illettrée puisqu'on n'arrive pas à lire
donc le braille est absolument important
heureusement l'informatique apporte des
solutions nouvelles pour nos amis
déficients visuels
on a un tournant et en tournant du
numérique pour will wright on est un
tournant du numérique et avec de
nouveaux instruments comme celui qui est
là vous pouvez montrer la caméra montrer
le bout de votre tête comme ça on va
pouvoir le voir là voilà un petit
instrument qui est comme ça qui est une
plage une plage braille ouvriers avaient
gagné six fois les six touches ce qui ce
qui sortent en relief d'accord alors
vous connecter cette plage braille à vos
ordinateurs et la plage braille va vous
lire sur la plage braille qui est là va
vous lire tout ce qui est à l'écran
titre ce qui est à l'écran est vraiment
on peut écrire sirugue et nicolas oui on
peut écrire donc avec les six touches
non cuit correspondent 6 points et
combinaisons des six points on peut
écrire sur la plage braille
donc on a compris un tournant il est
aussi une plateforme numérique c'est un
des médiathèques et aux c'est un groupe
c'est un tournant parce que cette
nouvelle plage braille qui va être
commercialisé cette année ne vaut que
650 euros alors que mille 3000 euros les
précédentes étaient à 2000 3000 euros
donc ça va permettre à nos amis aveugle
extractives
es11 mots justes pour terminer ce qu'on
arrive à la fin de centre
cet entretien sur la médiathèque eole
qui une médiathèque en ligne proposé par
l'association valentin haüy on peut
retrouver des références en braille à me
retrouver deux il ya quarante mille
références à la bibliothèque eole qui
sont disponibles en braille numérique ou
en braille papier et on rappelle que
l'association cette année
malheureusement il arrive à la fin de
cet entretien fait ses 130 ans on aura
l'occasion bernard de gonneville d'en
reparler sur ce plateau
je vous en fais la promesse voilà merci
d'être venus a sur ce plateau journey et
vous êtes le président du comité de
ligne de l'association valentin haüy
merci également à erika nicolas
professeur de braille pour l'association
c'est le grand rendez vous des acteurs
de l'innovation à technologie qui se
déroule chaque année à las vegas le crs
a commencé ce mardi plus de 400
entreprises françaises
ils sont présents parmi elles sky escale
one portal société qui est basée à saint
quentin en yvelines c'est sa quatrième
participation au salon le sujet de
nicolas landry ce n'est pas un jeu vidéo
mais une solution destinée au secteur de
la santé son nom nous vers ce produit
présenté au cs 2019 de las vegas et
conçu par la start-up sky one portal
basée à montigny le bretonneux
je vais utiliser cet écran tactile pour
manipuler l'expérience changer la
vitesse de déplacement ajouter des
ballons des obstacles et
le forcer à effectuer certains
mouvements pour éviter les obstacles ou
attraper les ballons l'objectif c'est de
forcer le patient à effectuer certains
mouvements générés un conflit
sensorielle entre ce qu'il voit et ce
qu'il ressent physiquement
cette solution a été développée pour un
kinésithérapeute du pôle vertige
équilibre de montigny le bretonneux
déstabiliser le patient en faisant
disparaître la route accélérée ou
reculées des manipulations pour générer
un conflit sensorielle le but c'est de
les forcer à ne plus s'appuyer sur l'or
sur le visuel mais un peu plus sur leur
oreille interne ou la somme est asie
c'est à dire le corps dans l'espace créé
en 2014 sky one portal est spécialisée
dans les solutions à usage immersive
lors du cs 2018 à las vegas la société a
créé un partenariat avec créative works
pour sa plateforme de jeu immersive
aujourd'hui créative works construit nos
produits pour le marché états unis dans
amérique australie nouvelle-zélande et
on a aussi un distributeur sur le japon
ok la marche est aussi assez spécifique
mais c'est vrai que c'est aussi des
territoires où le notre solution de
divertissement fonctionnant très bien
nouer des partenariats pour la
distribution des produits l'objectif de
la participation au cs avec à la clé une
activité dynamique
depuis sa création la start-up réalise
entre 50 et 100 % de croissance et on
interviendra cette entreprise en direct
depuis las vegas ce sera cette semaine
dans le journal
même avec le développement des ventes
privées elles restent incontournables
les soldes d'hiver commencent demain les
enseignes peaufine les derniers détails
pour faire face à l'affluence des
clients reportage au centre commercial
parly 2 au chesnay de marylène yapi
chine ont encore quelques étiquettes
accrochées avant le grand départ des
soldes d'hiver la course à la réduction
commence mercredi et dans les magasins
on s'organise on était en vente privée
avec déjà des pourcentages de remise
hélas les soldes officiels demain on
rajoute des nouvelles décotes et
on change certaine décote dans cette
enseigne de prêt-à-porter le rayonnage a
été retravaillé pour l'occasion les
vêtements sont rangés par taille pour
que le client puisse mieux se retrouver
moins de stock à écouler pour cette
petite bijouterie mais quelques soldes
quand même pour se faire plaisir
nous avons également des petites
pastilles qui sont dans nos vitrines qui
permettent à nos clientes de reconnaître
en fonction des couleurs dès pastilles
des différentes réductions que nous
allons avoir sur les différents bijoux
avec les fêtes de fin d'année les soldes
d'hiver sont
les plus gros rendez vous de l'année
pour les commerçants c'est le moment de
l'année où ils vont se dés stockées en
proposant des promotions très des
réductions très agressive de moins 30 à
moins 50 sur la première démarque pour
effectivement ce déstocker et faire
entrer ensuite la nouvelle connexion qui
9 janvier au 19 février c'est tout le
centre commercial qui se mobilisent des
renforts en sécurité en nettoyage
accompagne la fluence supplémentaire
pour se reposer dans ce marathon des
bonnes affaires le centre propose à ses
clients un espace détente et même une
bulle cocooning pour le premier mercredi
et samedi
donc on a toutes les soldes ici donc
interne au magasin
et ensuite effectivement il y aura deux
stands qui seront mobilisées sur la
place centrale
donc avec deux personnes qui seront qui
sont déconseillés esthéticienne qui vont
proposer ses prestations pour les
clientes
sur les premiers jours des soldes le
centre commercial parly 2 enregistre une
progression de 30 à 35% du nombre de ses
clients est la suite à présent de nos
focus sur les faits marquants de 2010
huit directions avril à juin dernier
avec au programme déplacement
ministériel fusion de communes a vanté
ou encore anniversaire c'est avec
mélanie poké un cabinet ministériel
délocalisé à saint quentin en yvelines
marlène schiappa secrétaire d'état
chargée de l'égalité entre les hommes et
les femmes s'installent à trappes durant
trois jours 3 que ce qu'on ressort c'est
qu'il ya une vraie richesse attrapé à
d'initiative et un esprit très
accueillants très sincèrement beaucoup
jour m'avait déconseillé d'aller à
trappes avec tous les clichés négatifs
qui peuvent être véhiculés sur la ville
au contraire moi je vois des gens qu'il
faut énormément de choses qui se bougent
qu'ils prennent des initiatives
le territoire yvelinois est
régulièrement visité par les ministres
ceux de la cohésion des territoires à
saint-cyr-l'ecole la ministre des
affaires européennes à bazoches sur
guyonne et david douillet quitte la
présidence des républicains des yvelines
il a annoncé arrêter la politique
à l'issue de son mandat de conseiller
régional en 2021 et des fiançailles a
raté maurepas et coignières n'envisagez
pas un tel scénario
le 9 avril les deux communes annoncent
leur volonté de fusionner un projet
dénoncé par les oppositions municipales
et des citoyens après un mois houleux
la décision tombe le 7 mai la fusion est
enterré
peut-être un peu d'incompréhension et
notamment sur les études
puisqu'aujourd'hui s'agissait que d'
études il y a que des études qui ont été
présentées en conseil municipal
il était dit que la fusion serait votée
le 2 mai il en a jamais été question
une nouvelle tête du côté de la
préfecture des yvelines serge morvan
nommé commissaire général à l'égalité
des territoires
c'est jean jacques brot qui s'installe à
versailles du côté scolaire l'heure est
au changement à elancourt l'école
regarde vers le futur
au revoir tables et chaises alignées la
circulation des élèves et favoriser un
projet nommé bouge ta classe en juin du
nouveau pour les rythmes scolaires de
septembre 2010
8 90% des communes choisissent de
revenir à la semaine de quatre jours est
des retours et des premières après
plusieurs mois d'étude la racine la
monnaie locale de la vallée de chevreuse
a été mise en circulation en juin une ou
non utilisables à son lancement dans une
vingtaine d'établissements des premières
aussi dans le sport avec le semi
marathon de la ville de trappes 168
coureurs étaient au départ on avait un
besoin un amant qui existait sur cette
ville c'est que les trappistes couraient
tous individuellement mais ne se
retrouvait jamais ensemble pour une
course unique pour qu'on a choisi
d'organiser cette année
elle répond à un vrai besoin est des
saint quentinois champion des yvelines
les basketteurs norvégien de moins de 13
ans remporte le championnat façon chez
mais les mauraciens sont moins chanceux
en football pour la coupe des yvelines
seniors c'est cuit en cours qui s'en
posent eux viser la coupe du monde les
bleus s'entraînaient pour la dernière
fois en public à clairefontaine avant de
s'envoler pour la russie où ils seront
sacrés de quoi ravir les supporters et
pas seulement voilà j'en ai de la terre
d'accueil toujours extraordinaire et
puis on est on est là pour la france 1
et soutenu non on est soutenus nous
avons pas voilà toujours en plus de
rencontrer les supporters
on passe un bon moment avec eux et ça me
permet de voir tout le monde québec
en cyclisme le mois de juin 2018 rimer
avec champions et anniversaire les
meilleurs coureurs tricolores se sont
affrontés à mantes la jolie à l'occasion
des championnats de france elle la
revanche a fêté son 20e anniversaire
plus de 160 coureurs se sont alignés au
départ c'est cinq fois plus que lors de
la première édition
c'est une tradition c'est c'est
l'histoire de saint quentin en yvelines
l'histoire de cette colline ce site
il était à l'abandon et accueil vraiment
nous notre club qui utilise aussi des
lacunes d'elancourt un anniversaire
aussi à thoiry en 1968 paul de la
panouse construit un circuit safari
cinquante ans plus tard plus de 750
animaux sont présentés eux auront
travaillé deux ans de la découverte de
la musique classique aux neuf mois de
répétitions sur scène les artistes
amateurs et professionnels de génération
lully ou créer une oeuvre est ce qui
fait l'actualité peut parfois être
insolite ne vélodrome nationale a été le
théâtre d'une compétition inédite
extraction chalenge avec 19 équipes de
pompiers venus de toute la france
après 2018 2019 aussi réserve de
nombreux événements ont parlé du sport
hier la culture sera au rendez vous
également cette année mélanie poké
bonsoir ça vous êtes allé piocher dans
la programmation des salles de
spectacles environnantes à quoi doit-on
s'attendre
déjà le premier rendez-vous grégory
c'est un texte bouleversant qui a été
porté sur scène vous n'aurez pas ma n
est écrit par antoine leiris alors
d'abord c'est un post facebook que le
journaliste écrit après la mort de sa
femme hélène au bataclan il en écrira
par la suite un livre adapté sur scène
par benjamin biya qui est aujourd'hui
interprété par raphaël personnaz et
c'est à découvrir
à versailles les 17 18 et 19 janvier
je dois rejoindre mais ville qui se
réveille de sa sieste
il va prendre son goûter
comme tous les jours
[Musique]
et je vais jouer avec lui comme tous les
jours et toute sa vie ce petit garçon
vous fera l'affront d'être heureux et
libre à 2010 9 être aussi l'occasion de
fête un anniversaire le 51 gospel passe
cette année un quart de siècle
et oui un anniversaire célébré là aussi
au mois de janvier c'est à la ferme de
bel ébat 25 ans de partage autour du
negro spiritual du gospel urbain et du
rythm and blues à la rend 25 ans grégory
plus de 120 concerts en région
parisienne principalement mais aussi
jusqu'à stockholm stockholm pardon sur
soc sur scène 70 chanteurs huit
musiciens
extraits
coc
il y a
bah
deux rendez vous donc au mois de janvier
sur le reste de la saison
alors pourquoi ne pas se rendre à
l'espace fibre noire et des clés souvent
à ceux des clés sous bois là vous
pourrez découvrir la dernière création
d' alexis michalik intra muros avec son
chéri c'est quand même edmond alors je
ne peux pas conclure son site elle est
tête d'affiche dans le désordre jane
birkin à montigny le bretonneux manu
payet et arthur h hae lanco christophe
alévêque à maurepas fait chatterton
attrape ou encore celle à à plaisir je
sais pas vous ridoré mais pour moi ça va
être très difficile de choisir
effectivement c'est en ces grands
enfants on les retrouve également dans
votre émission de 7,8 culture mélanie a
retrouvé tout à leur merci pour cette
chronique
ça pourrait être mélanie l'un de vos
prochains coups de coeur culture bonsoir
que retard ansa vous êtes originaire de
montigny le bretonneux race peur de 22
ans du quartier de la sourde oreille et
vous avez fait le buzz en fin d'année
avec votre cube thierry jam sont dans
les coups tout de suite en extrait faut
que tu saches que j'avais peur la joie
de passer simplement le rêve nos défauts
nos qualités
avec amour et sa série
ge sera plus pour l'asie que si noir
j'ai rappelé apprendre un peu plus
rappelé siegfried ma fille est en vérité
j'en parlais façon illimitée
[Musique]
on sait c'est un extrait du clip je
rappe avec votre ancienne voie curetage
qu'on va parler un peu de votre histoire
on va peut-être pouvoir tout de suite
écoutez un extrait du clip kery james
mais sachez que ce sont n'est pas une
plainte plus tôt un simple constat
j'ai des amis qui ont plus de problèmes
quatre bulles dans leur canette de fanta
c'est un bordel mais trop d'enfants
d'yves la peau sur les os et à l'heure
où j'écris ce morceau des tonnes de
nourriture soit debout bévue tuning que
je rappe la misère le monde la
planétaire c'est sûr qu'il aimerait un
jour pouvoir il voit grandir ma fille et
son frère
mais le véritable problème c'est l'homme
oui l'homme avec un grand h
déjà quatre fois que je le cite dans ses
textes en compte l homme saoul qui sort
sa femme tape et alors il a été hué à ce
jour plus de 261 1600 x qui rit james et
sept minutes
kurt à vous raconter ce qui se passe en
france et dans le monde est-ce que vous
vous attendiez à un tel engouement
autour de ce clip non pas par l'otan
c'est vrai qu'en mettant le nom de kery
james et je savais que ça allait du coup
intrigués oui mais je m'attendais pas à
autant de vue dans l'histoire de ce
titre est particulière le 1er août 2010
8 vous fait opérer d'un polype aux
cordes vocales vous profitez de ce mois
d'août vous êtes enfermé chez vous et
sans voix dans votre appartement pour
écrire ce texte
écouter les musiques aussi d'un rappeur
du 94 kery james qui vous ont inspiré
d'ailleurs ce titre lui rend hommage
vous dites dans votre titre ces textes
sont des règles de vie ses écrits sont
des leçons il vous a aidé à avancer
kery james c'est vrai que c'est l'un des
artistes qui m'a énormément inspiré et
du coup ce mois d'août
à rester enfermée chez moi je ne serais
venu comme ça naturellement j'ai ré
écouter ses morceaux que je connaissais
déjà mais avec une autre oreille du coup
une oreille un peu plus adulte on va
dire et je me suis dit j'ai envie de
faire un morceau dans son style à un
morceau pas forcément de quatre minutes
avec deux refrains voilà un morceau
assez long et surtout l'idée de
véhiculer des messages comme il le fait
c'est bien on en parlera juste après
alors l'ultime consécration c'est que
kery james en personne à lui même
écoutez ce titre est à fait votre
promotion sur son compte twitter
ce rappeur il dit de vous ces mots ce
rappeur ali le fond et la forme j'ai
versé une larme il est la preuve que le
rap dit conscient ne disparaîtra pas
avec moi être adoubé par ce grands noms
du rap forcément ça fait beau ça face à
c'est un honneur pour moi c'est un
honneur c'est sûr ça m'a énormément
touché c'est vrai que quand j'ai vu le
nom devait exploser je me suis dit bon
ya un fort lien il ya possibilité que ça
et jusqu'à ses oreilles
mais après le partage mais surtout ces
réseaux est le message du cookie qui l'a
mis avec ça m'a énormément touché donc
voila et après j'ai aussi la chance de
le rencontrer en vrai pour leur mère ce
lors d'un concert au zénith voilà c'est
ça leur son de son côté rose aimée parce
que du coup j'avais acheté des places
bien avant c'était même je crois au mois
d'août quand j'avais vu qu'il faisait un
concert je me faisais a bâti un super le
zénith je vais aller voir
et puis avec le morceau etc j'ai eu la
chance de pouvoir le rencontrer et de le
remercier de vive voix pour ceux se
partage sur ce titre vous l'avez dit
vous avez écrit de la manière à la kery
james et un rap conscient est ce que ce
rap conscient qu'ils portent davantage
un message qui est davantage basé sur
les paroles sur le texte et ce qu'il a
encore de l'avenir puisque dans les
radios c'est parce qu'il passe le plus
on va dire moi je l'espère c'est vrai
que
le rap c'est une branche musicale
et puis il ya plein de rap on va dire
différents c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui on
entend un peu plus de pop urbaine ou
deux morceaux un peu dansant ou afro les
messages textes se perdent un petit peu
mais il ya quand même beaucoup de
rappeurs même pas très connu mais qui
font du rap qu'on peut appeler du coup
conscient et j'espère moi en faire
partie faire partie de l'avenir de ce
rap conscient mener des réflexions lors
entendu en début d'entretien vous avez
changé de voie avec cette opération aux
cordes vocales à le nouveau curtat cette
année qu'est ce qu'on peut lui lui
souhaiter avec ça avec sa nouvelle voie
quels sont les projets c'est vrai que
l'objectif c'est de continuer sur cette
lancée là ça fait des années que je
rappe plus de dix ans mais voilà il ya
l'âge qui passait vu cette opération est
maintenant je suis encore plus déterminé
surtout avec ceux partagés et cette
validation entre guillemets du grand
kery james
donc on peut souhaiter et on va dire une
continuité avec plein de nouveaux
morceaux et pourquoi pas un projet vous
souhaite en tout cas et les
saint-quentinois ont pu reconnaître dans
vos clips des lieux de
montigny-le-bretonneux aussi le campus
universitaire de guyancourt sur saint
quentin en yvelines merci kurt
adversaire nation à la retrouver sur
votre page facebook tout votre actualité
également voilà c'est la fin de ce
journal belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]